I've been told by people in real life it
hey you're a wimp on TV you look huge
that was Tom Hanks when et first met him
during his bosom buddies days back in
1982 and he really hasn't changed much
since then in honor of the 60th birthday
here are seven of our favorite Tom Hanks
moments I've known I've been a funny guy
for a long time if the world is broken
up into two different segments those
people who are funny and those people
who are not funny i'm on the funny side
it's as simple as that this we know it's
true I'm curious as to what you think
the quality is it that you have that
makes people consider you what the every
well i think it's i think it's the goofy
voice and you know on the big bus he
also never misses an opportunity for a
good selfie hey there was the time he
staged a drunk photo shoot with these
fans and that time he found this girl's
student ID and returned it i got my old
ID back a little note from him hey
Lauren hold on to this Tom Hanks here's
something else you don't see every day
yep that's Tom at scooter Braun's
wedding dressed as a rabbi singing this
is how we do it but if you thought that
was crazy just kidding
we really really really really like that
the respected actor was in carly Rae
Jepsen's music video but above it all
he's a real family man the father of
four has been married to wife Rita
Wilson for an astounding 28 years I
think the the end result is is that we
got married for all the right reasons
selfishly that right there is actually
my favorite tom moment the day I finally
met him and reminded him he won
back-to-back Oscars back to Batman yeah
he forget long time ago my friend he
called me his friend you guys